tensión y cruces de acusaciones en el
último gran debate electoral antes de la
cita del 2 de octubre los dos favoritos
el presidente ayer revolucionario y la
expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
se han enfrentado en varios momentos y
que han acusado recíprocamente de ser
mentirosos hay que recordar que Lula
tiene técnicamente un 50% de intención
de Voto mientras que evolucionaron tiene
un
36%, es decir Lula podría ganar Incluso
en la primera vuelta y por eso en los
últimos días hemos visto una campaña a
favor del voto útil por parte de
aquellos que temen que puede haber
disturbios en el caso de una derrota de
bolsonaro creo que destacar que en el
debate se ha habido muchas acusaciones
pero os he hablado poco de contenidos
hablan poco Los candidatos de lo que
quieren hacer con Brasil en el caso de
ganar concretamente Lula iba a desvelar
Cuál es su plano de gobierno a lo largo
del mes de septiembre pero su equipo de
campaña ha decidido no hacerlo con las
disculpas de que todavía están
recibiendo ideas y sugestiones por parte
de los electores en realidad Lula está
pidiendo un cheque en blanco a la
población basado en lo que él hizo
cuando era presidente entre 2003 y 2010
cuando Brasil se convirtió en la sexta
mayor Economía del mundo en el caso de
que gane en la primera vuelta tendrá que
explicar qué quiere hacer sobre todo
para reflotar la economía Mientras tanto
el ambiente en Brasil extenso el
Tribunal Superior electoral ha prohibido
que el día de las elecciones se
transporten armas y municiones lo que da
una idea de cómo está el clima en este
momento en el país más poblado de
América Latina